gennaro chiantese di schianto il maestro
sono molti nomi con cui viene chiamato
the negli ultimi anni è diventato uno
leli streamer più conosciuti in italia e
noi siamo andati a conoscerlo lui e
giampiero se non si è capito è colui che
riprende si era capito come mai
allora ha detto voglio farlo perché mi
piace per iniziare questo format dove il
porto persone a fare cose strane cose
tu sei il primo
cambio no no piace tantissimo fare
questa transita per uso non so se mi
faccio male a quello ci pensa giampiero
che anche stilaro in medicina
si prendono una cosa e non avercela però
comunque non c'è mai provato così
provato 8 va bene dal di quando avevo 18
anni che ci provo e una patente da un
anno è se stai ancora lì machina vedrai
perché
adesso
titolo stellina sono paoli niente non si
usa a napoli
10 10
c'è di schianto regala non avete
aggiornati a
martedì anche legati
ad essere migliore
stiamo facendo la cosa più giusta prima
di saltare sui trampoli che mangiare la
brioche è da una vita che voglio fare
questa cosa e non sono mai riuscito a
ragazzi
dai
9 di cisco non hanno voluto o che ci
sostituti sono tanti piccoli giampiero
che spingono oro jafari il valzer
spacca ieri
io penso fosse molto più facile si corre
si corre fa il denaro ai gennaro quanto
a chi mi alzo prodotti ma puzza di
scilla
[Musica]
comunque ragazzi siete un crossover
incredibile c'è queste questa scena non
esiste chiede d'acqua o che c'entra il
cameraman chi preferite di gennaro tu in
auto di un incredibile mangiava gpu e
impalata discuteranno bomber capace
chiunque sta un po più una chicca ma
importante tu che con gli alert ti
svegli da solo
ma l'aria
a posto
lo sci hd
[Musica]
e comunque un miglioramento netto
ce l'abbiamo fatta allora volgari
signoria life almeno una clip se vuoi
commentare ma la giornata è venuto io
esborso di arena abbiamo corretto
percorso attenzione abbiamo un atipico
tavoli gialli
impossibile
è impossibile
quello in mezzo secondo che questi 55
ecco un olimpionico e morto avuto questa
ora da parte
questo è l'ultimo perché poi uniamo
sugli altri ma questo va all'ultimo
stato difficile
il livello 6
[Musica]
come fattore casa prince of persia
riguarda toccano in fondo è impossibile
a 10 ore di live tanti giorni faccio un
mestiere simile capisco la difficoltà io
non ce la farei ma ma mai ma proprio mai
neanche due al giorno
esagerato 69
questa
restituisce
giocata come funziona
andreste il problema gennaio che io sono
molto più piccolo di quanto pensi tu
dici che la mattina venisse chiarita
duro ce l'hai alzabandiera ok allora
0 poi vedere cosa vuol dire avere il
titolo de il maestro metha ci insegna il
cane sono anche gli ormai
prova non ho visto ma come fatto non lo
so
[Musica]
d'amico madonna ragazzi per le viuzze
perché sono fare
di tutto non ho almeno che la camera con
tanto di
o agli omaggi futura fotogramma